you were nervous when you met Madonna
right I was yeah you had diarrhea I had
I got there a little earlier than our
yeah thank God because then I had time
to take a crazy I was feeling bad
like you know when you're too nervous
and you just get
my stomach was just so you're minutes
away from meeting Madonna you go this is
great and now I have to make a duty it
was crazy but thank God yeah I mean she
would know this probably now but at the
time she didn't right I understand
listen who's bigger in the business
that's crazy and then she was in a
studio and then she wanted to sing in
Portuguese and wanted me to teach her
ports because I was like I'm teaching
you something how could you teach her
Portuguese in that quick amount I mean
you you had a fanatic yeah phonetically
you had to go and teach her but she
lives in Portugal she she was living I
don't know if she lives right now but
she was living in Portugal and then she
she knew some stuff which which was
great and she's really smart so it was
good I'm gonna play you something right
now and I want to ask you if you know
what this is oh God I'm scared no don't
be scared okay oh my God okay
[Music]
yeah Snoop Dogg actually it's so funny
because Snoop Dogg he watched my Netflix
series my documentary right he called me
and said
I'm here for whatever you need from me
oh that guy's a player
wow and that is that I need you to be on
my songs and my records and then he he
said whatever song you want and then I
sent this song and he said yes he
recorded right away